there were some guys outside Robin got
confronted by them downstairs and so did
Gary Baba fui they have a rock band and
they can't understand how I'm not
putting their rock band on the
soundtrack they know that your CD for
the movie soundtrack is at the factory
being pressed yeah and they want you
they know that when you hear this song
You're gonna tell them to stop the
pressing really and put this song on it
you're kidding me I'll destroy millions
of dollars worth of pressing right and
here are the Jesus twins hey come around
this way guys this is the only show you
gotta get past the gorilla
they have
well I'll tell you something I I have I
am always open listening to new music
I'm not uh close this is why I told
everyone this is why I I'll send but
tell me what's going to happen Howard's
going to hear your music in 30 seconds
what's going to happen he's gonna come
I'm gonna come over to your house this
is the only lyrics this is the only
lyric lyrically it fits a song the movie
I don't see any other songs besides you
wrote this specifically for the movies
the soundtrack has already been pressed
yeah now how come I haven't heard of you
guys before I mean yeah
oh you did you're 23 years old and
you're musicians and what do you play we
both sing We both sing and we write the
songs okay no instruments
you're still playing instruments no just
ask what are you Kurt loaded get out of
here
this guy's this douchebag doesn't
realize that with the best dances the
best thing is in the best songwriters in
the country right now you're adequate at
all those and bad at some of them why am
I listening to this douchebag Play the
song all right let's hear this what is
the name of the song by the way feel my
ubiquity feel my ubiquity all right here
we go speaking to the people here we go
quiet
[Music]
sit down sit down sit down sit down sit
down first of all let's discuss this as
rational people
it was awesome yeah listen to me awesome
we made it through the first verse
where's your music you're in your
basement still you and your uh you
haven't done anything you want to know
somebody's bet it's better in my face
you haven't done anything you're a loser
I'm here and that's why you're
struggling your sound effects man you
press a button you press the button how
is that Talent it's right open for Ozzy
who do you want yourself let's play um
exactly a ding dong sound why do you
guys have to why why is everyone
attacking each other these guys are
getting on my nerves I think it's time
to bring in the manager you're a manager
yes all right let me meet your manager
real quick all right all right and then
and then let me think about all that has
occurred all right
it speaks for itself I don't even know
why I'm on the show there's no doubt
about that it speaks for itself
here is your manager now do you manage
any of the groups or is this your first
time managing when I was 17 years of age
I managed a group called vice president
let me get away
yeah this is my first professional group
other than that and I could say that
what did you do before let the man speak
well I'm actually the vice president of
an entertainment company
getting away from that getting away from
that Howard right now my main concern go
ahead okay Howard what is your concern
my main concern is taking this group to
the top right making all other issues
irrelevant these two gentlemen right
here the Jesus twins the threshold to
the next decade all right look the Jesus
twins have made their point what do you
think what do I think
what do I think of the song you want to
know right now I can't put it on the
soundtrack why because it's already been
pressed it's too late you got to be too
late all right let me let me address the
question here
forget the soundtrack go ahead what do
you think of the song itself
oh you would have to ask that are you
guys gonna get them beat me up if I give
a negative response no not at all I will
look that's what I mean
soundtrack I'm gonna tell you what
soundtrack is over let's forget the
soundtrack listen to me the soundtrack
is irrelevant you asked me what I
thought of the song the soundtrack is
not good this song is so Innovative I
want to back you guys
100 percent then what how do I get it
how do I own these guys I'll tell you
how do I get rid of you what power it
I'll tell you what what you give me
three million dollars we'll talk yeah if
I give you three million dollars I can
own these guys if you give me three
million dollars all right let me think
about it let me think about it that's a
big that's a big commitment on my part
I'm not saying you're not worth it
I'm saying I got to think about it you
can't say it what say what
what you really think of the song it's a
nice song it's an okay song
it's an okay song it's not horrible
ought to be horrible I said it's not
honorable I was expecting a lot worse
what are you a lot worse this is the
best song ever any song you have on
thank you for coming in today let's see
Gary's dumb smark when it's in the movie
yeah let's let's take a break follow me
to the movie and watch my Dev smirk when
it's not
good good all right go ahead help the
guys out of here
all right boys I uh Jesus twins thank
you good luck good luck you did a great
appearance today you had your music play
there go the Jesus twins
foreign